Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
This'll be my Full
Loki Season 2 Episode 3 Video
There's a whole bunch
of Easter Eggs and references,
and now we have so many new theories
about who the big villain of season
two is going to be.
And possibly even one of the major
villains of, like, Avengers Secret Wars.
Like, there's a whole bunch of new theory
just born after this episode.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I'll also start doing the weekly giveaway
for the Spider-Man 2 game.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know how
you think
Miss Minutes is going to become
the big villain of season two and possibly
an even bigger villain beyond that,
in like the next Avengers movies.
Careful for spoilers
If you haven't seen the episode yet.
we already know.
The Council of Kangs
is going to be the main villain
for most of at least Avengers five
because it's called Kang Dynasty.
But potentially Miss Minutes could now
be like the big villain of Secret Wars.
Be like that other big villain
because they don't
want to do the exact same thing.
Like all we're doing, Council of
Kangs is the villain in Avengers 5.
We don't want them to be the exact same
villain in Avengers 6.
this whole episode basically made the case
for Miss Minutes being a much,
much bigger villain in the making.
She just needs to get that body.
All she wants is a body.
She'l basically turned into like a new,
more advanced version
of Ultron, like the version of Ultron from
What If version got the Infinity Stones?
She's now worse than that.
Because she would potentially control
time.
She wouldn't need the infinity stones.
the actual episode title was 1893,
which is a reference to the 1893
Chicago World's Fair
It was called the World's
Columbian Exposition.
pretty much the entire episode
revolved around that event.
the actual opening scene begins
with the Marvel logo.
But instead of the traditional theme song,
they played the old timey
piano version of the theme song.
Maybe the release that on the soundtrack
pretty soon,
it actually sounded pretty cool.
They did that to all the traditional Loki
theme music during the episode.
Like they play a lot of different people's
themes in the episode,
but old timey versions of their themes
just to be period specific.
We find out what happened to Renslayer
after she left at the end of season one.
So when she arrives here in 1868
with the young version of Kang
and she finds Miss Minutes,
this is meant to be like right
after she left in the season one finale.
So they're showing us what happened
on the other side of that portal.
Like that's
why she's wearing the exact same outfit.
She's holding the same one
that she just struck Mobius with.
And here's the important thing to like
denoting where they are in time and space.
When it shows the timeline point here,
it also says sacred timeline.
so probably one of the other biggest
reveals of the episode
is that Victor Timely
Kang isn't just a variant of Kang.
He was he who remains
from the original sacred timeline.
Like this is where he
who remains came from.
But because they gave him the TVA journal
from the far future.
It was sort of a bootstrap paradox
situation.
They turned him into a like
that was a nexus event
giving him the journal
and that's why he became a variant
and he's going to be completely different
from he remains that he will develop
in a completely different way that's why
they're turning him into more of a hero
this season.
They wanted to position him as a nicer
version of Kang in this episode.
Unlike he who remains,
who was a little bit more sinister,
a little bit more willy Wonka, too.
By the end of his timeline, he probably
wasn't that crazy the entire time. yet.
Remember that by the time we're meeting,
he remains.
He's been a life for millions
and millions of years.
And that's how he's turned into the Willy
Wonka version of Kang.
he was way more mentally stable earlier
when he knew revolved around
Slayer during the Kang Multiverse War.
the whole idea is that the TVA
journal is basically meant
to contain all knowledge of the TVA.
How everything works.
Basically all of his advanced concepts
in help the younger version of Kang
become much more powerful, much faster,
which is a big comic book concept.
So in the comics, Kang
does stuff like this all the time,
but usually it's just like one version
of Kang from across his own timeline,
with different versions from the past,
present and future, all working together
to make each other more powerful
in the areas in which they live.
Usually it's the Kang
This the furthest into the future,
working with past versions of himself
to make himself more powerful
in the future by making himself
more powerful in the past.
the way that Miss Minutes explains it
to Renslayer, though, is that this was he
who remains playing like in
case things go wrong break glass
and this is the break
glass Plan B scenario.
this means in the original version
of the sacred timeline,
he who remains started out in 1868 here
that eventually developed
all these time travel concepts.
All this technology eventually learned
about other worlds, other universes
met the other Kang's
and then became more powerful, controlling
time, becoming the he who remains version
of Kang winning the Kang Multiverse War.
Learning about alive.
Like everything plays out there,
he creates the TVA with Ren's Slayer.
we find out how he created Miss minutes
before all that happened.
Don't worry I'll get to that part too.
Because it's all about her
evil monologuing like we catch her
evil monologuing for great length.
At the end of the episode,
Miss Minutes changes into the old timey
looking version of herself.
The design looks a little more like it's
based on classic Disney cartoons
like Steamboat, Willie and the other funny
detail here, too, like this
is a really specific thing for animators.
when she changes
to the old timey version of herself.
She's no longer a perfect circle.
Like you can see
wavy points in the lines here
and there's just another reference
to old timey animation,
the other idea is the color
didn't really exist the same way too.
That's
why she's the black and white version
the only other weird detail
about this version of he
who remains being born in 1868,
I think is the idea that all kangs,
at least in the comics,
are meant to be born
at the exact same point
in the 30th century,
like in the vastly distant future.
so this version being born in the distant
past is like a big, big change.
but in this new version of the timeline,
that the whole idea is
that when Sylvie killed, he
who remains the timeline, rebooted.
He was obviously born again in the 1800s
like he was the first time.
But they're using this bootstrap method
where they give him advanced knowledge way
before
he was originally going to get it in
unless there's a big left turn,
like he winds up dying at some point later
in the season, he could wind up
becoming the prime version of King.
The whole idea is that in any given time,
the most powerful version of Kang like,
there's got to be at least one
who's the dominant one.
He's called the Prime King.
the plus tier version of Kang.
there was a joke about this during Loki
season one, where they referred to like
the top looks like the main
Loki as the superior Loki.
That was.
We are making the jokes
about how alligator Loki
is the superior Loki when she slips him
the TVA journal.
He's already working on an experiment
like he's already meant to be
an inquisitive child,
showing you that the DNA was there.
Like the idea was there that he would
eventually become a version of Kang.
It was possible, even without the journal.
the other interesting thing here too,
is that he opens the journal and the idea
is that he knows how to read, which is how
he can read the actual journal,
because literacy during
this era was terrible.
there were extremely large portions
of the population
around the world that could not read
and could not write.
but the idea is
that he did have the potential
that he did know how to read and write
because he was way
smarter than everyone else, even
without that future knowledge.
they also give him some of his own
Kang theme music here too.
the next important detail here
too, is when they go back
to the TVA in present day,
they're looking at the monitor
and it's in black and white
instead of color like it was before.
Normally
you would think this is because Renzulli
and Miss Minutes just changed the timeline
because they create a Nexus event.
Giving this version of Kang,
the TVA Journal.
kind of like a back to the future sports
Journal kind of situation.
but the TVA is meant to exist
outside of time, like in wild times space
so that it's not affected by changes
in the timeline.
So no matter what Renzulli or Miss Minutes
or even this version of Victor
Timely Kang did,
the TVA would still be the same
in present day.
But this is obviously their way around
the temporal aura because apparently,
even though he becomes a variant of he
who remains his temporal
aura is still the same.
in Victor timely also connects
with the concept of aura borrows time
repeating itself the title of episode
one like himself from the Future,
trying to help himself in the past.
does this also make you feel like
it was Loki from the future,
also saving him in the past
by pruning him in episode one?
Like, it just makes sense now.
They're doing the same thing with the
he remains in Victor timely kangs
if they're doing something like that,
that would Loki also use that same trick
but interestingly they're actually trying
to find Miss Minutes
so that they can save the timeline here
by finding Ren's Slayer.
They're not even thinking about the Kangs
or this new version of Victor
Timely Kang In the past
They go back to 1868
in that same location, the same alleyway,
because they got the hit from Renslayer
tempered.
I didn't see the newspapers on the wall
like some of the texts in the background
was a little too small.
So if you think you can read this text,
let me know in the comments
then obviously the reason
why they go back to 1893 is because he
who remains king was 25 years older.
He become an adult in actually had time
to develop some of these inventions
using the TVA manual.
they travel to the Chicago world fairs.
We saw in all the trailers, Moebius makes
a bunch of period specific references.
Chicago
was also called the White City
Thomas Edison.
There were a couple of jokes
about Thomas Edison and references
in the episode with the robber Baron
Victor Timely Kang is also kind of
like the Nikola Tesla version of Kang,
and he was Thomas Edison's rival.
He's also the rival of the Robber Baron.
In the episode two letter
kind of at odds with each other.
H.H. Holmes
that Mobius mentions was also a famous
or infamous serial killer from that era.
But notice when they come to the World's
Fair on the timeline marker
here, where it says 1893,
it says they're on a branch timeline.
That's because when they gave young Victor
Timely Kang the Journal,
they created a Nexus event
and he became a variant of he who remains,
which is why at the end of the episode
he tells Sylvie, Look,
I'm totally different.
I'm not that guy that you hated,
that you just killed a little while ago.
setting up the idea that he could
potentially be one of the heroes
this season.
Like the big twist,
the big pivot from season one, like,
Kang isn't the main villain
because we thought that he was going to be
one of the big villains
during this season.
really Miss Minutes
is probably going to be the main
villain of the season.
Rensselaer acting like she also wants
to be one of the big villains.
But really, I think Miss Minutes
is the more sinister of the two Now.
but this also explains
why he becomes Victor
Timely Kang instead of he who remains
like he calls himself Victor timely
all the different things
from different universes,
like all the different variants
are the same way too.
They only go by one
alternate name like the dramaturg Kang
only ever called himself Romita.
the amortized version of Kang
only ever called himself Immortals.
Like all the other different
comic book personas
In the comics, though,
that's what they were like.
It was the same.
Kang Just using different masks, different
personas across his own timeline.
But. To be fair, Victor Timely.
Kang in the comics
was originally a variant in the comics,
but they did have the concept of variants
in the comics before they did the Loki
series, the little kids selling newspapers
here, talking about the Liberty Bell
that was commissioned in the 1700s.
so when he's talking about it
debuting in the 1800s,
that might just be an example of how
the timeline has changed
in this alternate universe.
he mentions the ghost clock
haunting the Midway, which is obviously
Miss Minutes.
Mobius picks up on that
pretty quickly, clocks it, so to speak,
to make as many time puns as possible
because she's literally depicted
as the face of a clock.
most of the text on the rest of this
newspaper is too small to read,
but they bake Easter Eggs
into this kind of stuff all the time,
like did on She-Hulk, all the other Marvel
series, the other Marvel movies.
So if you think you can read
any of these other articles
like Zoom, Enhance a thousand times,
let me know in the comments.
They also do an old timey
looking circle wipe, which is also
a staple of star Wars
movies and Star Wars TV shows.
they make a bunch of jokes about.
Moby is trying to make excuses
to enjoy the actual World's
Fair, like he's just having fun.
He enjoys eating the sweets.
Loki seems like he can't stand it,
like he has a big problem
with sweets themselves.
It tastes like ash.
there was a big joke about that
during season one where Mobius is like,
Don't you have candy on Asgard trying
to basically tell Loki to chill out?
when he said they have grapes and nuts
and he thought of that as Candy Mobius
used that as an excuse to say
why Loki was so hard up all the time.
Like, Dude, just chill out,
have some regular candy.
To his credit, though, he did say that
he enjoyed the key lime pie.
So Loki has eaten some sweets
and enjoyed it.
there's a huge deep cut Easter egg for the
comics at the Norse Pavilion exhibition.
They've got an exhibit
showing this alternate branched timeline
universe version of the current Asgardian
Pantheon of characters.
So like, this is what they look like
in this alternate universe.
they make a huge joke about Loki not being
there, but there is balder, the brave.
So bold are the Brave is a marvel
comic book character.
He's one of the brothers of Thor.
He's been around in the comics
for a long, long time,
but they haven't done him in live
action yet.
They were going to do him during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
he was going to be played by Daniel Craig,
who had a bunch of scheduling issues
and had to drop out of the movie.
And instead they did John KRASINSKI'S
Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four.
the writer of the first Thor movie
also said
that they tried to get Bolt of the Brave
into the first movie, but at the time,
Marvel executives were like,
No, no, no, that's too much mythology.
Like too much for casual audience members.
They won't get it.
that was what Loki meant
when he said later Bow to the bray.
People don't even know who that is.
that was meant to be a reference
to Marvel executives at the time,
telling the writers,
People don't even know who that is.
People who don't read the comics.
but I think what they're also saying
here in this exhibit is in this alternate
timeline, this version of Odin
never rescue Loki as a baby.
So he never became part of their family.
love and making that funny
dig authority like Thor isn't that tall.
they clock Victor
timely signed temporal Marvel's
another Marvel comic book reference.
There are a couple of those in the episode
like Victor time.
We also says Marvel later
the other people on the scene here,
like Ferdinand Lang, Carl Boom were real
people during the 1800s though.
So for the most part,
everything here is meant to be
pretty close to what it was like
in the original version of the Chicago
World's Fair.
In real life, when they mention
Renslayer, they play her theorem
in base the music again and we see her
who has most minutes in the bag.
Victor Timely
does this big presentation on time travel.
The device is meant to be a prototype of
the temporal loom that we see at the TVA.
He's basically showing it off,
giving this presentation like Nikola
Tesla would be explaining electricity
around that era.
he makes a reference to the TVA book
when he says
he knows more about the future than that
man might think when he questions him.
like I say,
kind of like the Sports Journal
from back to the Future to then Loki here.
Also later in the episode
Miss Minutes, a couple other characters
also make specific reference to clarify
that Victor timely is a variant of he
who remains.
He is not the exact same
he who remains that's why this world
fair is happening in a branch timeline,
not on the sacred timeline.
He shows them the battery,
which is also way more advanced technology
for that time here,
showing how he's already benefited
from the Journal itself.
he shades Thomas Edison
kind of in a Nikola Tesla kind of way.
the whole metaphor.
He uses lighting a whole city
using a single bulb is also a reference
to the TVA, basically running the TVA off
the equivalent amount of power.
like, this is meant to be a small model
of the way that things actually wind up
working at the TVA.
the man who's trying to get
the rights from him is literally
subtitled is being called robber baron.
And he is a literal metaphor
or a reference to Thomas Edison,
not the actual Thomas Edison,
but just a reference to him.
because in real life, Thomas Edison didn't
actually create the light bulb.
He was just really clever at gaining
the patents for a lot of this technology
and had really clever lawyers
for controlling the technology.
that's how it wound up working its way
into homes in the United States
and becoming the dominant form
of that electrical technology
which we see even in present day.
So Thomas Edison became kind of
like one of those classic robber
barons from the 1800s,
Like he had a lot of thugs, quote unquote,
working for him like this robber
baron does
when he offers him $1,000 in the 1800s,
that'd be kind of like $1,000,000
in today's money. Like a lot of money.
but the whole joke here,
which Loki correctly calls out,
is that essentially it's a confidence
scheme.
He's a confidence trickster,
and Loki himself is the God of tricksters
like he is the God of mischief.
so essentially the victor
timely version of King is pulling a trick
from Loki's book, so to speak, a trickster
recognizes a trickster.
This was a lot of comedy
during this part of the episode too,
because of the big twist with the victor
timely king like no, no, no.
He's a confidence trickster.
He's not actually trying to take over
the planet or anything like that.
He's just trying to earn a quick buck
using the tech from the TVA,
Loki uses as magic
to send that dude into the pig cage.
Vader timely also referred to him
as a wizard and to Mobius as his butler.
Loki didn't hear that, but
he would probably laugh at the thought.
Mobius is kind of like my butler.
like the whole idea is that the duty slips
the money to was in on the con
within the whole time.
And he drove up the bidding by saying that
he wanted to take, like, all bid
for this right now, getting the robber
baron to pay him even more money.
Just confirming it with the councilman's
electric trousers.
Like what? I'm not any taller.
Apparently the trousers
were supposed to make him feel way taller.
Maybe that was also a reference
to Marvel's
Stilt Man, which was the character
during the Daredevil Netflix series.
Like you see the Stilts in the background
here.
Stillman of the 1800s Spider-Man
noir is actually an old timey version
of Spider-Man two, so there's a lot of old
timey Marvel heroes, in there, things
like 1602 like Elseworlds Marvel stories
that take place in the distant past.
There are couple of weird moments
when they confront
each other in the street here, too.
It's like Loki and Mobius
don't immediately
jump for Ren clears throat
or for Viktor Time Lee's throat.
probably to foreshadow
the idea that even though Rensselaer
seems like she's on the path
to becoming a villain
this season, like she wants to control
time, she might wind up helping them
because Miss Minutes might wind up
betraying her.
like a scene from the episode.
They're positioning Ms.
Minutes
to be a much bigger villain this season.
so I think that was why Mobius was making
all these references here to Renslayer,
coming back to the TVA and helping them
fix it.
Like, come on, just help us out.
Victor.
Timely runs to hide
at the ancient Egypt exhibit,
which is another king reference to Rama
Tut when he gives him
the slip on the Ferris wheel,
they play the old timey rendition of the
Loki theme music with the piano version.
Sylvie shows up on her own to kill him
because of what Loki told her.
Then Sylvie notes that they're now,
ironically in the same situation
they were during the end of season one
when she killed he, who remains Loki,
was trying to stop her
They played that scene from the trailer
where Miss Minutes comes out of the bag,
creating the diversion for them.
Just confirming, though, that this was
always the main version of Miss Minutes.
It wasn't like the alternate timeline
version of Miss Minutes.
Important to note
looks like Loki also kind of hates
bicycles a little bit like no way
he's going to ride a bicycle
for two with Mobius.
Maybe if it were a jet ski for two,
then when they're inside the little shack
here and later in the episode two,
you start to watch Miss Minutes
reacting to Ren, Slayer
and Kang like clearly
see the chemistry between Rent Slayer
and K because she fell in love
with He remains king
and he's meant to be just like him.
You can definitely see that Ms..
Minutes starts to get very,
very jealous of her.
I also love the idea that Victor
Timely Kang basically made like,
the most bachelor invention ever.
like it's a comfy chair was set Cooler's
seat heelers and a little fridge
for your drinks like he puts beer in there
that is like the most dude thing to create
ever.
Like are you going to create something
that's going to help you
control all of time?
No, no, no.
He's going to create a really comfy chair.
just more evidence of this Victor timely
version of Kang is a much nicer,
way more chill version of Kang MZ Min.
It starts to explain a little bit
about her backstory,
confirming what most people believed
about her from season one.
Like she's an advanced
artificial intelligence
that he remains created before
the Kang Multiverse War and before he met
Renslayer as a device to just play chess
with like an advanced game machine,
which I also think is a reference
to the computer from war games
like something that just plays chess
but is actually becoming very,
very dangerous.
Shall we play How about
global thermal nuclear
for when he makes the joke about actually
doing business in Wisconsin?
Like this is where my real lab is
because the taxes are cheaper there.
That's actually a reference to comic book
Victor Timely in the comics.
He was a variant of King
who went back into the past and created
a town called Timely Wisconsin,
setting himself up as the ruler,
connecting the town
with coronavirus in the future.
The TVA is basically like the MCU version
of Colonel Bliss in eventually he becomes
the prime king which isn't too dissimilar
from what they're teasing here.
Like they're trying to get him
to become the prime king,
even though it seems like he doesn't
have an interest in actually doing that.
when they board the steamship here,
the SS Herron, it's a reference
to Kate Herron,
the showrunner from season one.
The reason
why she didn't come back for season two
is because Marvel waited so long
to renew the show for season two that
she'd already booked a couple other gigs
and had to go on to those other cases.
Just scheduling issues,
the little joke
about the usual accommodations
that he asks for is, that they're free.
They're free accommodations
like they travel one of the lifeboats,
so they have to pay, the couple of time
travel jokes here where he talks
about how the journal changed his life
and then he suddenly realizes
that it was like,
you're the person
that gave me the journal.
Then you see more of Miss Minutes
trying to undermine her, basically
calling her like a glorified mail person.
They also make a funny joke about him
fanboy over Aura Burrows like Casey did,
and he's going to meet him in episode
four, like, you're the guy or a Burrows.
Also probably remember him too.
Like, you're the guy.
the papier maché flower he makes her
is another reference to their romance
from the comics
in the one that they reference
in the tape that Loki listen to
in the original timeline.
Miss Minutes
also seems really happy to get rid of her.
I think this also supports
the idea that in the original version
of the timeline, Ren's
Slayer had her mind wiped and forgot about
he who remains version of Kang
because of something that Ms.
Minutes did
like convincing he who remains to leave
and go to the Citadel
at the end of time Ms..
Smith also probably convinced him
to create the time keepers
that the whole concept of the timekeepers
making her more of an antagonist
this season,
even though the way they in the episode,
they make it seem like
Renslayer will also become
one of the main villains.
It just feels like she's going to be
betrayed by Miss Minutes at some point
They arrive at his lab in Wisconsin.
He's got another temporal
loon prototype in the background.
A lot of prototypes for things
that you see in the TVA and present day.
this device that he calls
the culmination of his life's work
is the amplifier device that he referenced
earlier that he's going to use
to fix the temporal loom.
And the
But this is where things really start
to turn on a dime and miss minutes
goes from like kind of sinister
to full blown comic book villainy.
she starts getting super creepy
and preventing him
from going back to the TVA like
she sounds like she just wants him
to create a body for her so
she can be with him and they can go off
and just do whatever with the two of them.
Like she doesn't care
about controlling time.
She just wants to be with him.
she evil villain monologues.
The rest of her backstory basically
explained that she has her own autonomy
now to write her own programing, basically
becoming like a worse version of Ultron.
that was Ultron's
whole thing is that he wanted
a more powerful body,
which was going to be vision
love the way he also starts to clock her
being more evil.
Like he puts his bag in his lap, like,
okay, like somebody please help.
He barely forces her back into the temple
before she comes at them.
but when she says that he who remains king
prevented her from getting a body,
it just sounds like he never cared about
her in the same way she cared about him.
And it turned into like a big Yondu
raid thing to make an anime reference
like she is the world's
worst Yondu right now.
only.
She's something on the scale of Ultron.
Probably worse because she can control
time.
doesn't this kind of feel like her arc
for the season?
Like she will try to eventually
give herself a body?
Renslayer whips out the prototype
for the TVA pruning wand
this are to set her up as more available
until like she's obsessed with order.
she wants to rule the TVA
which is a twist on comic book rentals
or like comic book rentals
or died at some point.
And that's what drove Kang
into much greater villainy.
Funny enough,
she actually died during a comic book
story called Kang Dynasty,
which is the title of Avengers five,
I believe that was also the storyline
where the Victor timely version of Kang
became the Prime Kang.
There's a great scene between Victor
Timely and Sylvie.
She comes back and gets ready to kill him,
but he basically gives her
the same argument that she was pissed off
at Renslayer about during season one.
Like, the whole idea is that
Sylvie was persecuted her entire life
and and treated
like she was just like all the other worst
versions of Loki, when in reality
she was like a completely different person
making completely different choices.
So like, why were they mad about her?
She was just a little girl.
She hadn't done anything yet.
Victor Timely.
Kang basically
tells her the exact same thing.
Like, I haven't done anything yet.
Like, I'm totally different.
I'm not that guy
that you just killed a little while ago.
I'm going to make
completely different choices.
setting him up for more of a hero
arc this season.
Unless there's a dramatic left
turn with the character
in the last couple of episodes,
The act of sparing him is just to show you
how Sylvie is growing as a person
and also throwing it in ren space.
Like, be careful what you wish for.
And she sends her to the end of time
to show her
what her life will eventually turn into.
Like This is how everything
is going to wind up for you,
Basically the idea that the obsession with
this will become her downfall
like it would have been for Sylvie.
She hadn't relented
like it would have been her downfall.
And it will ultimately probably be Ren
Slayer's downfall.
she sends her to the end of time.
Enough time has gone by since she killed.
He remains for his body to decay.
But you see
the signal itself is falling apart
because he's not there to restore it.
She releases Miss Minutes.
Who finishes saying she loves him.
She meant he who remains
even though it's her time.
We came now in present day
then they make it seem
like they're going to team up
for the rest of the season
and become the main villains.
but I think the idea here is that
they're really more like frenemy is like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend.
So they don't really like each other
necessarily.
It's just that Renzulli Ah needs Mrs.
and Miss Minutes
for some reason, also needs Renslayer
mostly to get herself a body Miss Minutes
also confirms a lot of these theories
to basically saying that she's now
Victor Taiwan's enemy
like it was foolish of him
to make an enemy of the person
who knows all of his secrets.
flipping the script from season one and
everything we saw from the counsel of Kang
so far, like a Kang variant who's good
and actually wants to help all the heroes,
how the tables have turned.
But it's kind of like this
in the comics too.
Like there are many other
Kang variants in the comics.
Some of them are better than others.
Some of them are really, really bad.
the Loki showrunner also revealed
this season that we might wind up
seeing like the ultimate version of,
like the prime version of Kang.
They didn't say who that would be like
if it was going to be Victor, timely
or like another version of Kang
He referred to it
as the definitive version of Kang,
which is basically like the Prime Kang,
the little teaser that Ms.
Minutes gives randomly or at the end too,
where she says,
I have a secret that you don't know,
but it's going to piss you off big time
is probably the truth of her back story,
I think the idea is at some point
she had her mind why
she she forgot everything about
he remains in their fight during the Kang
Multiverse War, creating the TVA
in the first place during episode four Ms.
Minutes might also take her back
to the sacred timeline
to show her what her original life
used to be as the schoolteacher
here in the events that led to her
joining Kang in the Multiverse war.
during the end credits,
they changed a couple of the scenes.
There's new scenes in the 1800s.
Victor
Time Lee's temporal Loom prototypes.
This scene of the model is them in episode
four, creating a new plan
to fix the temporal loom.
There are couple of new files here
that someone is examining.
It's Rensselaer with the prototype
of the pruning one Victor timely.
During his presentation, the younger child
version of Victor Timely 1868,
then Sylvie
Loki Mobius at the World's Fair.
My earlier theory is that
these are meant to be mobius files
like they were depicting Mobius
examining them.
But there's an African thumb
pressed on one of the files,
so it might be Hunter B-15
examining the files like
it might have been her
in all these different episodes.
Let me know in the comments.
Who do you think is actually the person
examining all these different files?
Like it just feels like Hunter B-15
at this point because that thumb
then at the end of the credits
they have another new scene of the younger
victor timely opening the TVA manual
next week Victor timely obviously
going to help or Ambrose and the others
fix the temporal loom moment.
It's like I said,
probably going to take Rensselaer back
to show her what her original used
to look like on the sacred timeline
and reveal everything about her backstory.
this is all the stuff you forgot.
This is how we created
the TVA in the first place.
Let me know in the comments.
How long do you think
it's going to be before Ms..
Minutes betrays her and becomes
the big villain of the season?
Like, do you actually think that Ms..
Menace will be the real main
villain in season two?
And do you think that she could
potentially be one of the big villains
in like Avengers five or Avengers six?
like I said, she is basically like a worse
version of Ultron.
Advanced artificial intelligence.
This super evil
now in wants a more advanced body.
there were so many Easter Eggs
and references in the episode.
If you think you spotted any
that I didn't talk about in the video,
particularly like the little text,
like the articles in the background
that were super small,
just write them below in the comments
Overall is probably my favorite episode
so far.
Like you said,
way more fun in this episode.
It's way more stuff going on, way more
cool lore from the comics to generally.
It really feels like
the actual plot of the season
has become like things have really gotten
started.
We're halfway through the season two,
so we kind of expected things to pick up
pretty quickly.
my Episode 4 Trailer
video will post tomorrow.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that
I'll update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Loki episodes.
Thank you so much for watching everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!